Hey how is it going Bros
My name's PEWDIEPIE
Welcome back to The Walking Dead
We've just met Clemen- Cleme- Cle- Cleme- Cle *wut?*
My girl my boo.. shit
Ok, here we go
She's so.. pretty
So she's the one that did it
[laughs]
She's a BADASS!
Oh my God, you got a-
[laughs]
Awwn Clemy.. she's so Cute!
Does Clemy even know how to drive?
How old is Clemy? [14 years old]
I hope- I hope that wasn't a weird joke
I just realized it clearly was..
Listen I just wanna ship them, ok? That's all
Awwn
I prefer her voice now actually
It's smoother
Before it was that
Eh, Clementine-
Now it's just
Clementine
It's cool, she's cool
I'm so excited
Oh, wow, what the fuck is this arm doing?
More bald people..
Clemy wouldn't waste ammo, that's right
She know how to del with this guys
Right through the fucking mouth!
I've been around..
Why is Clementine alone?
Well, he is still tied up..
Muertos..
That's one thing that is really weird to me about The Walking Dead
is that they never refer to them as "zombie"
It's something like Walkers or crawlers or muertos or puertos..
There you go
The ones that run?
Does that mean there are different types of Walkers?
Ookay..
Oh great..
[laughs]
Lee..
My man
She clearly knows her way around
She's stil wearing the cap
-OMON!
Ok, we're heading to the van, the giant van
Is it you..
Ok, let's keep playing
It's about to get intense!
Oh we've got some people..
It's spaz time!
Come. WOOH!
oooh!
Okay what? Oh thanks! Appreciate it!
Nice man bun. Loser! Fine!
Alright. Uh... Boom!
Bim!
Bazinga. Bazinga
Headshot all around. Now what?
Don't worry Clemy, I gotchu
uhh let's save Clemy
You're fine!
FUCK YEAH CLEM! OH MY GOD! THAT IS UGLY!
It's like a- A FUCKING HORSE!
What is happening like (his face lol)
(Laughter)
Oh my god, this is me as a badass
So
The walkers, I mean the zombies
Prescott...
The walk in- they move in herds
And there's little cities around now even. Or outposts. That's pretty cool.
Woah
Looks like uh very Fallout-y
It's called a silo, thank you very much (sassy pewds)
Double gated...
Well clearly, he's worried about his family.
(Clementines face has a seizure) What is that?
Ooookay!
Oh, cause she brought the bullets of the gun and.. clearly they didn't work, huh
This is very cool! I'm much more intrigued by this universe.
She's so cute!
I'm the new Lee, huh?
This is great
I really enjoy this
Let's look at this guys
Why not?
They look so nice, what is he-  what is sh-
Clementine mean with the people here?
What does that mean?
We- we used..
We used to be famous..
for gambling?
Well I'm the expert, right?
Call his bluff..
Hey
[laughs]
Hum hum
Hey no problem
Clemen, she's so cool!
He looks like such a..
trust for the person
Wow shit!
Hum hum
Ohh shhh..
(dat faece man)
Ohohohoohoho
Doesn't seem that bad!
you know atleast they're safe
see? what is service?
**poods in heart melting emotion**
we've always been
HUAHA
OHOOOOO!!
SALUTE
kinda just sleepin' on the fuckin' floor
I would- i would trust--
I trust Clemetine more than I trust anyone
OKAY?
I've been with her, why should I trust Eleanor?
I'll g-I'll go with Clementine's advice
I know I--
eventhough I really like to go
thought we already had a sleep?
AOW
AOW SHIT GOT DARK
for a sec there what the fuck, she was happened
what the shitty da shoodie da booty
What is this?
OWH
Backstory?
Ehhhhts.. me?
Oh it's a Baby of course!
OH my god
she was straining the baby like-
JUST TOMATO SAUCE
JUST tomato sauce
Kenny's hat!
whoa
this is wellington
holy sht
aaaaaaaaaaaoooooohhhhh
siet
O my God
oh
what happened to AJ then?
we don't know yet
*creepy voice* we don't know yet ..
ohh Clementine..
is this da-day 2?
**that poods face tho**
GOT HIM
I mean, at this point i don't even care if this guys are still there
like i'm not invested enough in them
i don't really givashit
I don't know what we'd expect then
That was one of them Clementine
that was one of them
wasn't that hers?
GOOOT  HIM!!
MAH CHOCOLATE
The cassette player!
HAAAUHHH
Yes!
awwwnn
But you didn't listen nooww.. BAM
I'm Mr. Viking
don't mind me
Ah shit that was our deal
sorry Clemmy
oops
Could that be her?
Ah it's them! How 'bout that..
A grenade will do the trick.. REHP
Ohh..
Oh it's fighting time BABY!
It's ass kicking time!
PLUHP
Ouu
Jeez
Ohh doug.. you got snooked on
Axe MUDAFAKA!
Oh that one look like a kid
Jeesus..
Oh shit.. ernn
Got him!
Hey how 'bout that? They are all dead
You're welcome!
Yes, but I have another girlfriend now!
Don't worry about it
Mehh..
Ohh
Ouu..
Ok..
Alright..
alright
Well.. I got kidnapped!
Are you the new Duck?
humm
Or is it?
Let's go on a trip, Tripp!
She's not a kid!
So emotional Clementi- Hey, I guess..
Whatever..
The ambulance?
You really need to just throw those away, ok?
And I have the batterie, I mean I have this thing
[screams]
WHAT??
Ohhh!
Ohh! Ohh!
WHAT THE SHHIT
You jinxed it! You jinxed it, alright
Ohhh..
Oh my God
No!
Fuck!
Noo
You guys are dumb!
Oh my God
I gotta come with them right
Leon- No, not Leon!
Lonny- Lonny, whatever
Not Lonny!
Anyone but Lonny..
FUCK YEAH! Clementine!
That was episode oneee!
Ties that bind..
Ohh.. wo Ohh wha ah ah ah
That was awesome!
That was so short..
That was just 1 hour- less th-
That was almost just an hour- that's..
That's probably why they.. let
We have.. we have another episode thank fucking God!
I understand now why!
People would be like:
What the Fuck! I waited for this?
That's cool though!
"Did you stay the night at the junkyard?"
"You and 56.."
Okay, well..
Alright
"Did you shoot the driver?"
Oh a lot of people..
A lot of people decided to shoot, huh?
I wouldn't have imagined that let him go
But he was such an asshole. I don't like him!
And I've got to prove myself to Clemmy
Ernn
88% of players got locked up, huh?
Okay, well fair enough
"Who brought you to the junkyard?"
Everyone decided with their dick and balls, huh?
Alright, fair enough..
"Did you escape with your family or stay with Clementine?"
That's an obvious one!
C'mon!
Easy.. 'course I'll stay with Clementine!
Alright!
-ery cool! I'm so glad that we have 2 more episodes
that we can play
I mean, it's 1 more episode but I'll split it into 2
I love playing this game!
I- I'm so glad is back! You know?
It's fucking back, I'm so excited!
It's so cool to see how Clementine's character has developed
It's so cool in the universe
That is more interesting
It's le- it seems li-
I don't know episode 2 was a little whiny & mony, ok?
I- Am I the only one that got that?
"Oh everything is so bad!"
Here things is moving foward
You can tell the universe has expanded
In- into- in- in different ways
I think is really awesome
But yeah..
Leave a like if you enjoyed watching
I'll see you tomorrow with episode 2!
We're lucky, huh? Thank you Telltale!
You fucking rock man!
[blows a kiss]
That one's just for you man
I- I think I'm
I- I- I've been shitting a lot of the other Telltale ones
but I'm just honest, ok?
I think..
I think- this one is really good and they deserve for 'em
So..
As always stay awesome Bros!